what's it like to be out in science to
find out we talked to LGBTQ scientists
about their experiences as well as to
researchers studying the issues that
queer people in STEM fields face I've
had a mixture of positive negative and
neutral experiences as a gay man in the
Natural Sciences I grew up in an area of
North Carolina where it was very
challenging to come out at a young age
and maybe only out gay person in my
middle and high school for many years
and so I compared that to now living
south of San Francisco working at
Stanford having started in Poston
chapter getting a talk on the
experiences of my community to me that
speaks volumes to the progress I've seen
so when we think about STEM innovation
we want the best and brightest
individuals to be able to stay in stem
and thrive in stem and social biases
that come into play
really Rob STEM innovation from the
kinds of contributions that people from
a variety of different backgrounds can
make and so the more diverse our
research teams are the better science
that Lea little conduct that's the
question our lgbtq+ people
underrepresented in science and the
answer is we don't know because we
aren't accounted I suspect or
underrepresented we've learned that most
stem workers are not out at work and so
a lot of people are showing up to work
and going back into the closet in stem
so why is it important that we're
physicals because people need to have
role models if they see somebody like
them and make connections they're more
likely to stay retained and engaged in a
profession and we know this from our
personal experience we also see that the
experiences of harassment being
misgendered having an incorrectly
assumed sexual orientation a really
common experience is and so those can be
really challenging factors to face on a
constant day-to-day and they take away
our energy to focus on our research
right like anytime someone says
something you know gives you a slight
right it can be distracting to our work
when LGBTQ students get good individual
mentoring from faculty like a trans
student realizes that their professor is
willing to use the name and pronouns
that they use or they're able to talk to
them about some of these personal issues
that they may not feel very comfortable
bringing up with their peers that it
really makes a difference for them and
we also see that welcoming climates
foster better productivity for all
scholars in STEM fields not just LGBT
and non-binary folks but also straight
and cisgender folks who work in STEM
fields in welcoming climates their
productivity metrics that we measure are
also higher so welcoming climate
benefits all so I feel optimistic
because people who have been in stem for
a long time who are LGBTQ are optimistic
so when I talk to folks who have had
decades long careers who in their 50s or
60s and have been in stem for a long
time they see that we've made a lot of
progress and so they can understand this
as not necessarily a linear transition
but something that is improving over
time even though we might see eveson
flows in that you know direction to our
progress so I'm an optimist through and
through that things will continue to
make forward progress if we all keep
challenging ourselves to do a little bit
more for communities outside of ours
you
[Music]